protocole jeu la firme a été un succès
il fait de nous l'un des rares pays qui
a réussi à faire revenir tous ses
professeurs et tous ses élèves
quand vous regardez les courbe
épidémique y compris celle de santé
publique france récemment c'est pendant
les périodes de vacances qui lie à la
plus forte contamination
et c'est justement en septembre et
octobre que grâce au travail de tous
c'est pas le sujet du ministre c'est les
1 million de personnels de l'éducation
nationale qui ont fait respecter le
protocole sanitaire et qui ont permis
ces résultats avec l'accélération du
virus on prend des mesures encore plus
plus strictes à la rentrée et dès la
rentrée j'ai dit qu'il y aurait des
assouplissements possible ce que nous
avons fait d'ailleurs la semaine
dernière alors évidemment il y a des
inconvénients dans ces situations là et
c'est assez facile pour une opposition
d'aller souligné les les inconvénients
néanmoins sur le terrain nous avons
réussi à ce que la plupart des écoles
des collèges et des lycées puisse
continuer à fonctionner de façon aussi
normale que possible
vous dites il ya une contestation il ya
eu 8 38 % de grévistes la semaine
dernière alors je sais bien que vous
pensiez que quand il ya une crise
sanitaire il faut faire plus de conflits
tu alité politique
moi j'aimerais que vous en fassiez - et
que vous regardiez les performances de
la france qui sont au contraire bien
meilleur que la plupart des pays
auxquels vous pouvez la comparer